just want to bring you um some breaking
news that's reaching us here at sky
center three improvised devices found
around london
viable explosives is what we are being
told our senior
correspondent david bowden at city
airport four is david tellers
yeah three of these things all delivered
to transport hubs
one of them close to heathrow one of
them waterloo station
and one of them here in the building you
can see behind me about 100 people
working there just after lunchtime
midday
they were all evacuated from that
building
and in went the bomb squad to check out
these suspicious packages or the one
here anyway
turns out this was a small device
capable according to the metropolitan
police
counter terror command of initiating a
small fire
they don't know why anybody would send
these things they don't know why
they were sent to administration
buildings not the actual airports two
airports
or the train station proper they were
sent to admin buildings like this one
the airport itself
is over there uh and the same at
heathrow
and they don't know whether these are
all linked but
the mo is exactly the same yellow jiffy
bag
inside a white a4 envelope with a small
improvised
explosive device but intriguingly
only capable according to the police of
starting
a very small fire k what whoever sent
them was trying to do
whether there are some more we simply
don't know no arrests made so far
the police clearly investigating uh okay
and they are telling people presumably
uh suspicious package you're not sure
what it is contact them
yeah i mean one of these packages was
actually opened
it did start a very small fire and set
the envelope on fire
but none of the others were the police
were called before anybody
uh did anything to it apart from notice
it was suspicious
yes keep your eyes out yes the police
will come and deal with it
there may be more we simply don't know
at the moment three of them
one at heathrow one here at city one at
waterloo
nobody hurts nothing really happened as
far as the
movements of people around the airports
were concerned this one stayed open
he throw clearly has stayed open and
waterloo the trains were coming and
going
it just affected the administrators in
the building behind me
they're back in now okay for now david
thank you thanks a lot
so uh what can we tell you we can tell
you as david was saying there just to
sum up
three devices they were jiffy bag size
a4 this is waterloo station that
happened
around about lunchtime before that you
see just see the sniffer dog there
couldn't you
before that there was a device that was
found
on or near heathrow airport in the
perimeter one of the office buildings
there a viable device all three of them
viable and another one
again around lunchtime found at london
city
airport so all three of those devices
thought to be viable
one of them did explode there could be
others
counter-terrorists say be careful